et puis retour sur le week-end avec le
succès de la braderie du canal
saint-martin rennes près de cent mille
curieux ont flâné deux jours et deux
nuits le long de ce grand déballage de
rentrer l'on trouve vraiment de tout
ambiance avec brigitte bros et ariel
nathan 40 francs la petite merveille de
francis ou dont vous rêviez depuis si
longtemps ne se trouve pas à la première
lueur de lampes de poche
les habitués de la braderie du canal
saint-martin le savent bien
ce n'est qu'après quelques heures de
chine que l'on tombe sur l'objet de ses
rêves
je possède la même en vrai
donc voilà collectionneurs ou amateurs
chacun y va de sa méthode pour dénicher
la perle rare
ici on discute on marchande et on achète
mais il ya une chance qu'on ne compte
pas c'est la persévérance je faire plus
en encore plusieurs rude mais après je
rentrerai chez moi pour ton et leur part
demain
c'est à force de chercher tout le temps
qu'on trouve un gros disque on va faire
un petit tour en valais en passant a
offert hier une demande voir s'il est
toujours montrée espérant que ça baisse
réservé aux riverains la braderie permet
à chacun de vider ses greniers avec plus
ou moins de bonheur a beaucoup de choses
à trois formes pour certains la braderie
est devenu une histoire de famille qui
dure depuis bientôt vingt ans maintenant
ma fille est née avec moi parce qu'elle
a des jumeaux de la pac la faire avant
et puis c'est aussi l'occasion de vivre
une fois par an une nuit pas comme les
autres
sous la tente ou dans son duvet jusqu'au
petit matin c'est tout cela à la fois la
braderie du canal saint martin on y
trouve de tout avec beaucoup de charme
et ça ça n'a pas de prix